[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to you Game of Thrones Season eight
episode five has a hell of a lot to
unpack from it and the penultimate
battle has one huge symbol at the end of
it that's causing some confusion and
speculation across the internet
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down the true meaning of the white horse
scene in the closing scene of the show
and discussing how it ties into the
overall law of Game of Thrones this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen the episode yet and don't want
anything ruined then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into
the true meaning of the white horse okay
so the first thing to take from the
horse is that it initially belonged to
golden company leader harry strickland
who could be seen riding it just before
the Battle of King's Landing we're not
exactly sure of how it managed to make
it through the fight but its appearance
at the end is symbolic on a number of
levels the first thing that we can
assume is that it was sent by bran to
rescue Arya out of the area and the
destruction around her bran is this
universe as Doctor Strange able to see
all of the outcomes and you can bet that
this horse showing up is no accident and
that has sent it to a score area for a
reason Ned Stark himself under white
horse and this arrival can be seen as a
helping hand from her family that will
help to rescue the character out of the
rubble earlier in the episode a girl at
Arya attempted to save can to be seen
holding a white horse and bran has no
doubt purposely chosen this creature in
order to remind area that Daenerys has
went off the rails and caused the death
of many innocent lives
reddit user named Mika said the
following which to me means a lot I
think the horse at the end has a much
more obvious meaning and over half a
dozen scenes in this episode we have
shown a young peasant girl and every
time you see her she's clutching what
seems to be her only possession a small
white horse figurine with stained legs
and quite a few of the shots with her
the horse is literally in the center of
the shot and it's the only white thing
so it really stands
sout even when she's struggling to carry
her mother she's clutching her little
horse then after her death the camera
literally stops and holds this shot for
a good three seconds and what do we pan
to right after a living embodiment of
the Guild's beloved white horse with
sustained legs the horse then just
stands there in the middle of the fire
and smoke and gives itself over to area
the horse is clearly tied thematically
to the girl area failed to save perhaps
it represents her spirit was simply a
reminder of the innocent girl that was
killed whom area plants hair bench
I think this holds a lot of weight and
though she could not save her Aria is
riding forth on something similar to
what the girl cared about the most in
order to take Daenerys down symbolically
the horse to me shows the downfall of
Daenerys and how she has changed over
the seasons in season one the character
was presented a pristine white horse by
Khal Drogo
whereas this white horse is war-torn and
amidst the destruction of Danny's deeds
and it cements just how far she has come
in addition to this a lot of fans have
pointed out that in the Bible chapter
revelations there is a verse that states
I looked and there before me was a pale
horse it's rider was named death this
could mean that area is death
personified and that she is riding to
bring an end to Daenerys who I'm sure
many fans will agree needs to be stopped
for me it's probably the best part of
season 8 so far and I can't believe how
much subtext can be taken from this one
interaction obviously I'd love to you
your thoughts on the white horse and if
you took anything else from it is this a
reach is this the best foreshadowing
ever comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of all the leaked spoilers for
the finale next week which would be
linked to at the end we've also just
launched a merchandise section for the
channel so if you want to support the
videos and get something out of it make
sure you click one of the links in the
boxes below this is a channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]